okay good morning
it being 10 o'clock i'm opening the
public hearing on senate bill 228 and i
call the prime sponsor senator bradley
good morning madam
chair good morning members of the
committee thank you for the record jeb
bradley from wolfeboro
um
i'm pleased to be here to be able to
introduce
senate bill 228 which was a bill that
passed on a voice vote in the senate and
had
near unanimous support at the public
hearing
i was asked to introduce this bill by
the society of
um
physician assistance i think it's going
to increase access to health care
especially in
areas of the state that i represent more
rural areas
it will help contain costs
and it will make sure that new hampshire
is an attractive state for physician
assistance
to practice
especially
given that maine and vermont have
enacted similar legislation
we use vermont's legislation almost as a
model for this
but
when i was asked to introduce this bill
i made it very clear to the head of the
physician's assistance that they had to
work with the medical society and the
hospital association
as well as oplc to come to terms on an
agreed-upon
bill
dave cussey is going to be here um he is
here representing the
physician's assistants and interestingly
he told me that
there's not a single
physician assistant able to testify
today because they all are overwhelmed
at work so
if ever there was um
an indication that this bill is
necessary i think that's it
a couple of things on the bill i think
that are important to note that it does
not remove what's known as the legal
tether or the relationship between a
physician and a physician's assistant
and it does not allow a physician
assistant to practice independently
that obviously was very important to
the medical society and the hospital
association
it does not absolve a physician from
liability if they have involvement in
the care of a patient the bill makes
this clear
what it will do is align current
physician assistant regulations to
better reflect how they actually
practice
medicine in today's modern health care
world
so the bill has five
components number one
it takes the existing legal requirement
that a physician and a physician
assistant sign what's known as a
supervisory agreement
that has to be on file with the board of
medicine
and it combines it with
the requirement that a health care
employer has a practice agreement in
place
two that practice agreement outlines how
the physician assistant interacts and
collaborates with physicians
and any other member of that health care
team
the bill calls this
a collaboration agreement
then the bill will make clear that
physician assistants are liable for the
care they provide
that physicians aren't liable
for care provided solely by a physician
assistant simply because they've signed
a collaboration agreement but again
the amendment that the senate adopted
makes it clear that this bill does not
indemnify physicians if a physician as
part of the care of that patient
the third thing is the bill allows a
physician assistant to directly bill the
public and private insurers for care
they provide
and receive direct payment from those
insurers
the bill makes it clear this would only
be allowed
when permitted by federal law and only
when appropriate based on the physician
assistance employer setting
fourth the bill stipulates that the
physician assistant does not need a
collaboration agreement to provide care
during an emergency or a disaster
which we've seen come into play
with covid but also other situations
in the recent past
and fifth
the bill makes it clear
physician assistants do not need a
collaboration agreement to volunteer
to provide basic medical care at summer
camps charity road races and similar
activities and lastly i just want to
touch base very quickly on the
one person that testified in opposition
to the bill an attorney representing the
association for adjustment
justice excuse me
that
requested that liability coverage be
required in the bill and if you look on
page six
starting
at line 22 it says that physicians
assistants
shall have adequate valid professional
liability coverage so
i'm happy to try to answer any questions
mr cuzzy who was involved in all of the
um discussions and collaboration on this
bill is also here
okay thank you very much senator are
there any questions representative
scitec
thank you senator bradley would you mind
going over the liability provision again
it sounded i've
had trouble understanding who's
who's on first
okay so if you look on um page six of
the bill
328 d18
i'll just read it i think it's pretty
clear
physician assistants actively engaged in
providing medical care
shall have adequate current and valid
professional
liability insurance coverage so it
requires them to have coverage
i guess i'm talking about when is the
physician absolved from liability and
page five okay oh that's all right all
right so
okay
other questions representative pearson
thank you madam chair thank you senator
bradley
the professional liability insurance
coverage that you're referring to
would that in layman's terms be just
simply malpractice or is that a
different type of
insurance coverage i think it's meant to
include medical malpractice and that
kind of coverage yes great thank you
other questions
all right siegdon thank you very much
senator thank you very much madam chair
and members of the committee
have a good week
david cousy
uh good morning thank you madam chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is david cuzzy with prospect
hill strategies here in town and i'm
here this morning on behalf of the new
hampshire society of physician
assistants
uh as senator bradley mentioned again
uh
due to the shortages and the you know
now the demand on health care now that
the pandemic is easing hopefully
permanently
unfortunately no members of the board
our volunteer board of the
physician assistants and i'll refer to
the society of physician assistants as
nispa
if you will throughout the testimony
nhspa
so i'm here on behalf of nisba's
president steve alexicos
and the 1 000 pas in new hampshire as
well as the dozens of pa students who
are enrolled in the masters of pa
programs at franklin pierce university
and at the mass college of pharmacy
and health sciences in manchester
as you might expect we we do support sb
228 as passed by the senate and i just
thought i'd take a second just for those
who may not be as familiar on this
committee with pas there's you know some
misconceptions that have been kind of
baked in if you will over the many
decades since the profession
was introduced to the health care field
many decades ago
but
pas
despite the name pas are not assistance
to physicians they are
in new hampshire they are licensed
medical providers and this is the case
nationwide who diagnose illness develop
and manage treatment plans prescribe
medication and often serve as a
patient's uh
principal health care professional
uh they receive uh af
they they do receive a masters and they
receive thousands of hours of training
before they are um
uh before they are
considered physician assistants and able
to practice medicine
and uh that this is the case in every
state uh they provide care in every
medical setting and every specialty and
they do improve access to health care uh
across the state and across the country
especially in rural areas
uh
as i mentioned uh they work in hospitals
medical offices urgent cares community
health centers nursing homes and and
other uh in workplace clinics throughout
the state
and they also of course work in federal
government agencies and at the va
medical centers including
in manchester
so senator bradley
did a great job introducing the bill
i'll just touch on a few more details
and representative scitec maybe i'll
give a little more detail on the
liability provision as well if
if i may
so i think
it is important to note what this bill
does not do first of all i know it's a
six or so page bill but this bill is not
in any way a major overhaul of pa
practice regulation this is
the there is no change in the regulatory
regimen for pas at all
uh there are no
real major reforms of any kind
that this bill proposes for pas there's
no expansion or change of the scope of
practice for pas uh i would respectfully
suggest to the committee that this
really provides as senator bradley
outlined five common sense changes to
represent uh how pas now practice in a
modern health care setting uh that you
know really need to be updated since uh
the pa statute was uh was created and
amended over the last many decades
as senator bradley mentioned this does
not provide a path to independent
practice for pas
period i know there's been one or two
folks who maybe have suggested that but
that is
not accurate and that is something that
uh
was important to the medical society
mr padmore is here uh can can uh can
validate that
um
21 states over the last five years have
introduced pa practice or passed and
adopted pa practice modernization
legislation most notably vermont and
maine
massachusetts has a bill pending
and new york state also has passed a
bill and so has rhode island
and and as senator bradley mentioned a
good portion of this bill before you was
taken from vermont
um
and again the goal here is to make sure
that we are attracting and retaining pas
that our regulations are in line with
other states and and are um are updated
so that there are no barriers to pa uh
employment here in the state and that
people are seen in the right place
in the right location by the right
provider
i would like to thank the medical
society
and uh and others for their
collaboration on the bill senator
bradley mentioned a lot of them other
supporters include convenient md amiskeg
health which is the community health
center in manchester uh north country
health derry medical center primary care
and the nurse practitioners association
they've all indicated their uh their
support and i'd like to thank the
hospital association the board of
medicine and oplc as well for their
collaboration
so
senator bradley mentioned how this bill
would create a collaboration agreement
all that is very simply is you have the
responsible supervisory
physician
form right now in current law that must
be sent to the board of medicine and
kept on file there also per regs you
have a practice agreement that must be
kept on file at a pa's employer that
really just says outlines how a pa
interacts with members of the health
care team if it's a physician if it's a
respiratory therapist other folks
and all the bill is doing is it's taking
that rsp
and that practice agreement
combining them together in one document
and calling it a collaboration agreement
so there's still that need to name a
physician and a pa with a signature from
both
and there's still a need for a practice
agreement we're just combining it and
that agreement will be maintained on
file at the place of employment
as the practice agreement is now so none
of that changes there's still that legal
tether
and there's still a uh illegal and that
will be in statute now a requirement
that a collaboration agreement is kept
on file uh those can be the
collaboration agreement could say
whatever the employer and the pa wants
but what the bill does is it says
it must identify at least
who the collaborators are
how the pa communicates with members of
the the health care team and when based
on their education training
and experience so
again not a not a big reform just i
would respectfully suggest a
streamlining of of the regulatory
process there
in terms of and in this representative
scitec this may help
address your question
in terms of the liability requirement so
right now pas can be sued for the care
they provide
but
right now
the physician who signs what is that rsp
form
they can be sued right now just for the
simple fact that they had their name on
that form they may not have been
they may not have had anything to do
with that patient interaction uh they
may have been seeing their own patients
who that whole time um but they they are
they can be sued simply because they're
on that piece of paper all the bill does
it says
that that no longer can be the case you
can't you no longer could sue that that
physician simply because they have
signed what would this bill would call
the collaboration agreement but it makes
very clear that that physician if they
are involved in any way shape or form
they are still liable
uh they can be sued if they were
involved in that patient interaction in
any way shape or form
even if it's just the pa picking up the
phone and and asking a question now the
liability of course would kick in that's
how it is now uh
of course but the the statute makes that
clear so we think that's an improvement
um the the liability issue is a has
always been a barrier to employment for
pas because
no other health care provider has that
requirement put upon them of course that
they're
that they have a legal tether to a
physician and so a lot of times
healthcare employers
or physicians employed by healthcare
employers they don't like to be on the
hook to be sued by signing these rsps so
by removing that
that makes pas perhaps a little bit more
attractive
when compared to other health care
employers when when they're
looking to
change jobs
the issue of direct billing again pas
are only they're the only health care
providers that cannot right now
bill directly or being reimbursed
directly from health insurers be it
public or private insurers
this is
general this is really kind of a niche
issue but it really impacts those who
provide care in more rural settings
this allows them to be able a lot of
these more rural health care providers
maybe don't have the administrative or
don't want to bear the administrative
costs so for the pas to be able to build
directly and take on that administrative
burden on their own is really what this
is all about in rural health care
settings in
big employment health care settings uh
you know if it's dr hitchcock others
this does not apply and does not require
any health care provider to have a pa
bill directly or be reimbursed it allows
that flexibility based on employment
setting
senator bradley mentioned that this bill
makes clear that a pa would not need
a
collaboration agreement
for providing emergency care uh i think
the good this is the good samaritan
situation uh car accident on the side of
the road of course they may not be able
to be physically uh or you know of
course it wouldn't be they're
collaborating physician would not be
present and they may not be able to
reach them electronically when they're
when they're rendering care that really
gets to this to that issue um
and then uh with the volunteer care at
charity races or things like that this
is just allowing pas to provide
you know basic
uh general care of course if someone had
a more serious injury there'd be um you
know there'd be a transportation to a a
hospital or something on those lines
they can volunteer at their child summer
camp
that type of thing and and they don't
need a collaboration agreement for that
so
i again i would respectfully suggest
that these are five
common sense
changes
to existing law again
uh no big overhauls here um and uh and
and again we appreciate the fact that
all all stakeholders were able to come
together to agree on a bill and and i
look forward to uh answering any
questions from the committee thank you
madam chair
thank you representative fellowes has a
question and then like us
thank you for taking my question um
do physicians
do physicians assistants
have
specialty training before they enter
into these agreements because
you know the ones that i've encountered
have all been
um under a specialty doctor like an ent
or
something like that
so do they have that training before
they start
or do they enter these agreements with
just a general
background in
medicine so when they uh
and this could apply to a
pa right out of
school or this could provide to apply to
a pa who's 20 years into their career
so the answer is they they must sign
that practice agreement and they must
have that
um
signature
agreement with the doctor right now it's
the rrsp we'd look to call it a
collaboration agreement when they start
their employment the practice agreement
makes clear though
that they can't do anything within that
specialty
that is outside of their education
training and experience
and so
if someone is changing specialties for
example i think would be pr or or either
new to a specialty regardless of
scenario they're right out of school or
they're coming from maybe uh you know an
ent and going over to urology
they the in in the law now would say
that they cannot
be
doing anything they could not be doing
anything in terms of providing care that
would be outside of their
training
uh education and experience so there may
be additional training uh that they
would that they would need to undergo
perhaps even before they start in that
specialty but there certainly would be
experience that the physicians
would would require before they're
allowed to be um
off doing anything on their own if
you're talking about perhaps a surgical
setting or something like that you know
a pa is not performing surgery or
anything along those lines
so let's just take the the ent for
example
so
this physician
assistant graduates from the physician
assistant program and this is going to
be his first job
and he's um
is
for whatever reason is going to work
with a
ent
physician
so
so i understand that this this can work
if he has a lot of supervision to begin
with and learns how to do you know the
certain procedures which are you know
not
too dangerous and
somebody's watching over what he's doing
but
this seems to
create a situation where
i'm don't have the confidence that he's
going to
get the supervision in the early years
representative
physicians assistants do get specialty
training of various sorts as part of
their they do rotations the same way
doctors do
so they might have we would hope that
somebody's right out of school would
have completed a rotation in the
specialty they're going to work in
okay that that is that's is training is
available
and may i madam chair uh so
the chair is is correct so they have
thousands of hours of clinical training
before they even uh are allowed to to
practice um
the same as nurse practitioners
who do not have any supervisory
requirement they can come right out of
school and frankly they can open their
own practice
so
with the with the pas
as as the chair indicated in addition to
the thousands of hours of clinical
work that they do before they
are licensed they also do have a
rotation in various specialties i would
also submit that
we're not changing anything that's
happening right now so the scenario that
you present is exactly what's been
happening for decades we're not changing
anything here so right now
you could go to your ent and you might
have a brand new
pa who you're seeing um but that pa has
been as i've said had thousands of hours
of training they've had the specialty
training and that that physician who has
employed that pa um is going to be if
especially if they're new um they'll be
a lot more inclined to uh be watching
over them and you know they won't be
taking the training wheels if you off
off if you will so again we're not
changing this bill doesn't change what's
happening right now
um
and and so i hope that that provides
some some confidence so yeah
yeah so i i i understand that the
procedure can be the same if the if the
physician is
um
adequately i'll use the word supervise
for for that new pa
but it kind of seems like it takes
the liability
and if and if he's not well trained the
physician assistant may do something
incorrectly and cause a issue
because he wasn't trained that's why
they have liability insurance
and that's why the
practice
if the physician the supervising
physician is involved they are also
liable
so i again so
the this would apply to
um
a nurse practitioner
uh or a pa at some point everyone is new
and and i'm not even talking about
what's in the bill this the bill
represents what is current law the only
thing the bill changes about
uh any regulation
is that we're not sending a document to
concord anymore we're keeping it uh at
work we're taking two documents that
must exist
per law and regulation and we're
combining them and we're just saying
they need to be kept at the
um at the practice and that's that's all
the bill does so right now there's a
practic all pas must have a practice
agreement with their employer if it's an
ent or whoever uh right now that
practice agreement is kept on file for
inspection um at the place of employment
the
their responsible supervising physician
is a separate piece of paper and that is
sent into the board of medicine all the
bill is doing is taking those two things
and combining them and combining and
calling them a collaboration agreement
so nothing is changing between what's in
current law
what's happening now and going forward
and and again the the way that pas
uh or nurse practitioners or any health
care provider provides care
and and how much what they're allowed to
do uh will not change under this bill
that that remains unchanged
thank you representative lekis thank you
um so concerning the uh professional
liability insurance coverage i'm just
wondering if um
this i mean whether the pas that are
currently practicing or either required
to have this
for other reasons or whether they pretty
much universally do what i'm getting at
is
is this a change for any existing pas
so the answer is yes and no if if i may
right now no health care provider
is required to cover any
professional liability insurance
malpractice insurance
period
in state law or regs no one is required
to do that
this bill would be a first this would
require that
of pas and pas only
uh and the and this was at the um
suggestion of the trial lawyers that
came up during the senate and so uh the
pas
uh because and now to get to your other
point
um
and
you the p anyone would be foolish to not
have
adequate liability insurance but as the
trial lawyers point out point out there
are the foolish among us uh and by the
way in this instance uh no physician
would be foolish to sign
an agreement with the pa if it's the
current uh rsp or the collaboration
agreement uh proposed in this bill same
difference
uh without
they would never sign an agreement with
a pa that doesn't have adequate
liability insurance but nonetheless as
we all sit here in this room we think
that that would be the case but there
are instances where people uh have not
so the physician assistants agreed in an
effort to maintain consensus on the bill
to accept
uh a liability a requirement law that uh
that they carry adequate professional
liability insurance and that the
definition of adequate be determined in
rulemaking by the board of medicine
the physician assistants would love to
see that apply to all health care
providers as you might expect i don't
they don't think that they should be
singled out but uh being quite candid
with your representative uh we agreed to
this change that was put forth by the
trial lawyers in an effort to make to
maintain consensus on this bill all
right thank you
representative judy
good morning sir morning
can you please explain me the difference
between a pa
and a nurse practitioner
sure well
the nurse practitioners were trained as
nurses
um pas and i'm i'm generalizing here so
bear with me and again
um i'm just i'm just the lobbyist so um
uh i i will uh i will let you know if i
if i think i'm
saying something i believe i know to be
the case but nurse practitioners were
trained as nurses and then they went on
to get the extra
the extra education and training to be
nurse practitioners
they
they come out of and they can practice
independently with no no supervise no no
supervision agreement or anything like
that they can open their own practice
day one out of school
physician assistants are trained in the
physician model i'm not saying they're
trained as physicians i want to be very
clear on that but they are trained and
there's folks in the room that can uh
that can correct me but they are trained
in the physician model
uh and they go through
um
and i'm not saying that nurses don't
just you know speaking more to what the
pas do in that physician model
uh they go through all the various
rotations the clinical hours uh et
cetera they just simply don't have
the extent of the education
uh and whatnot that a physician does and
so that i think it but of course when
they're done with their education
uh they are not allowed to practice
uh independently
at any point in time uh in some states
that's changed they are allowed at
either immediately or at some point in
time to practice independently uh
not not the case uh not the case with
with this bill uh currently or going
forward uh that is that's the real
difference it's really just that
there is two different education models
you know nursing versus the physician
model and then there's the um and then
there's the fact that when they're when
they're out of school pas can't practice
uh independently
thank you representative you had a
question
uh mr kazi i was concerned about
liability for this reason and you've
uncovered it the truck could it be that
the trial lawyers are insisting on this
coverage because doctors have more
assets than a physician's assistant
might represent
please do not speculate on people's
motivations
representative grota
thank you madam chair
so in essence since this bill really
doesn't change the way people
be between physician assistants or
practicing
this bill
therefore
you a
thousand foot view
is removing the board of medicine
from
certification of these
these
physician assistants and
the relationship between the board of
assistant board of medicine will be
between the physician who has signed
this collaboration document with the
physician assistant is that correct uh
if i may uh
uh
not exactly
the board of the board of medicine does
not in any way shape or form
approve or certify
the
the current rsp that responsible
supervisory uh physician
agreement between pas
and uh physicians so there's no approval
process from the board of medicine right
now but uh that regarding that
relationship all that happens is that
piece of paper gets mailed to concord
gets mailed to the mail to the board of
medicine uh and is kept on file that's
it um there are no uh the board does not
that uh certify any uh edu
educational uh programming or anything
along lower accreditation of pas there
is a pa on the board of medicine
uh the board of medicine not
they maintain all of their regulatory
authority over pas under this bill
the only thing that changes in terms of
what the pa what the board of medicine
does or doesn't do is that they now
don't get that piece of paper
that piece of paper would be combined
with the practice agreement and just
simply kept on file at the at the place
of employment
follow up
i must have i i'm sorry i rephrased i
phrased my question incorrectly okay
so the bill repeals the rulemaking
authority of the board of medicine
it repeals several things why is that
necessary
well
because um
so i think you're referring to the last
page of the bill
um
so this
a lot of these are being repealed
um
because they're not they're not needed
so for example um if you go to the front
of the bill
um
with continuing education
uh and with uh
i'm just trying i'm sorry i wasn't uh
i'm just trying to answer your question
accurately without misspeaking uh or
with uh
any kind of mentions on page two of the
bill for example
um
on line 20 this committee on allied
health education and accreditation that
doesn't that doesn't exist so that is
the rule-making authority those
rule-making authorities are what are
being repealed
um
so
those are the those are the issues that
are being addressed
in terms of rulemaking that um are
stipulated further in the bill it's just
to conform with what's being said
elsewhere in the bill
if if i hope i'm being clear i apologize
no you are thank you thank you
okay thank you
uh yeah that was my question is does the
board of medicine have general
rule-making authority over physician
assistance
yes ma'am okay because these
these appear to be very specific
and the bill
puts them in statute rather than in
rules yes ma'am okay thank you are there
any other questions from mr cousin
seeing none thank you very much thank
you michael padmore
good morning madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is mike
padmore i'm the director of advocacy for
the new hampshire medical society
i'm here today to speak in support of sb
i want to thank or excuse me i want to
start by thanking the new hampshire
society of physician assistants for
coming to us uh last fall to discuss
this bill um since i've been in this
role since 2018
we worked very very closely with the
physician assistants to make a couple
common sense
changes the statute
into rules a couple examples of that
were removing ratio requirements that
pas and physicians had
and then also removing the requirement
for a pa to have an rsp named prior to
licensure so um when they came to us
with this bill you know we really wanted
to figure out a way to
work with them and and and um
understand the things that they were
trying to accomplish with it and and
figure out how we kind of bring all the
different stakeholders together to to
come to an agreement and i do think that
this amended version of this bill
does reflect uh the concerns and and the
changes that all of those stakeholders
um wanted to make um so i i'll be brief
and and i don't want to be redundant i
think senator bradley and i think mr cuz
he did a good job of explaining what's
in this bill uh so i'll just thank the
committee for their time and would be
happy to answer any questions that folks
might have
thank you representative scitec uh this
i'm not sure if this is for you or mr
cuzzy who this agreement that don't no
longer get sent to conquer the rsp i
guess is now kept in a file cabinet in
the physician's office uh
medical practice who actually gets to
see it what's the purpose of it if it is
who examines it
so i think my understanding would be
that that document is required to be
held
if the board of medicine does request it
um so
you know prior i believe um the the rsp
that was sent to the board of medicine
um to be kept on file there
in this new revised edition i believe
the board of medicine has been consulted
on this
they don't need to have that unless they
do request it so if they request it then
then that collaboration agreement can be
sent to them
yes follow-up
does the bill say that
they have the right to who has the right
to see this by statute i believe it does
say in statute that um upon request uh
will be sent to the board of medicine i
can double check that but i believe it's
in there
it's
page 3 line 20.
representative pearson
thank you madam chair the agreement that
we're
beating to death here is that something
that an insurance carrier would require
to see as part of their
i mean i know you're not an insurance
guy but is that
is that logical i appreciate the
question i don't know if i can really
answer that um
yeah i don't know if i can answer that
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
mike for taking my question i'm asking
this although i think i know the answer
because i think it needs to be on the
record
my understanding as a hospital trustee
is that sometimes it is difficult to get
physicians to agree to sign these
collaborative practice agreements for a
variety of reasons
will this bill address our difficulty as
a hospital in
attracting physicians assistants because
we will no longer have that difficulty i
thank you for the question i certainly
would hope so you know i think one of
the the goals of the physician
assistants in proposing this legislation
uh to start was to hopefully streamline
that process and and make that um
that hiring process a little bit easier
for physician assistants and that
relationship between pas and physicians
a little bit more streamlined so i
certainly would would hope that that is
the case
thank you
thank you other questions
thank you very much appreciate that
marissa chase
good morning madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
marissa chase i represent the new
hampshire association for justice which
is a euphemism for the trial lawyers
association we are a statewide
professional association of
approximately 400 attorneys focusing on
represented plaintiffs and plaintiff's
rights
i wasn't planning on speaking today i
appreciate the physician's assistance
and the medical society and the hospital
association all the hours that they have
taken to talk with us and come to
consensus i do believe the bill before
you as a result of that consensus i just
wanted to point out a couple um
a couple points based on questions that
i heard of committee members if that's
all right
nhaj is neutral on the bill you know i
think any expansion of access to health
care for patients in new hampshire is a
good thing
but i think it's important to recognize
that
pas inherent in their title physicians
assistants and other mid-level health
care providers were never intended in
our overall regulatory and statutory and
licensing schemes to practice
independently
so i think it's important to bear in
mind
those are the reasons why we requested
those changes adequate liability
coverage is typically in a requirement
in a hospital's credentialing agreement
so that's how it happens now by calling
it out in statute because there it's
foreseeable that some physician
assistants would no longer be under the
umbrella of a hospital as they typically
are now
we felt it appropriate we were very
happy that they agreed to that change
as mr cussey said you know it would be
foolish in this day and age for someone
to not cover adequate liability coverage
unfortunately our members have seen that
to be true
and that is only when a patient is so
egregiously harmed by the act of a
health care provider which is rare i
want to point out it's exceedingly
difficult to bring a medical malpractice
suit especially in new hampshire we have
very conservative juries and verdicts we
do not have
what's the word pune punitive damages in
new hampshire so that keeps our jury
verdicts low
and i also want to point out especially
with this committee that i haven't been
before you before
especially with the pandemic
in new hampshire how a plaintiff's
lawyer brings a civil suit they take it
on what's called contingency fee that
means that the lawyer does not get paid
if and unless they prevail which means
that they are financially um
incented to not take a case that doesn't
have very clear liability
or high damages you know potential
future loss of income loss of enjoyment
of life etc
contingency fee also means that a lawyer
fronts all the costs of litigation up
front that means that they are
responsible for fronting the costs of
experts going through testimony
deposition we're talking thousands and
thousands of dollars so we do not have a
frivolous lawsuit issue in new hampshire
um i just wanted to you know kind of
clarify that for the record and i'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you very much representative marsh
and please don't ask questions you know
the answers to
okay well that might make it difficult
thank you for coming to testify before
us today uh as this bill is written are
the collaborative practice agreements
discoverable if the case goes to trial
that i don't know
i'd be happy to follow up with the
committee i would appreciate that
okay
other questions
seeing none thank you for waiting excuse
me representative fellows
so
so right now if a physician's assistant
did something that was bad enough that
it would
there'd be a possibility that they're
sued for it
can you tell me
who they would sue now
and
how this bill would make that different
in it i'm just generally trying to
the physicians already always have their
own
insurance or is it sometimes covered by
the the hospital or wherever they work
who who who covers the liability for all
the different options right now sure
under this bill
so unfortunately i'm going to give you a
complicated answer which i don't like
doing
um
it depends i mean it depends on the case
the specifics of the case
um
there's what is a complicating factor i
think plaintiff's lawyers get a a bad
rap and i get it but plaintiff's lawyers
typically get
i think blamed with naming so many
defendants in a lawsuit like anyone
could who could have touched anyone in
the process
in new hampshire it's not always the
plaintiff's attorney who is naming other
defendants because we have a case called
de benedetto
where defend it
i'll breeze over it i'd be happy to
follow up with the committee with the
many pages just the highlights just the
highlights a defendant can shift blame
onto other defendants and they can name
other defendants in a case because say
i'm a patient i had surgery i you know
they cut off the wrong leg god forbid
um the i sue the doctor who did the
surgery and the surgeon says well it was
actually the radiologist who gave me the
wrong information or it was the hospital
and they are able to name other
defendants so it's not always the
plaintiff's lawyer naming all of these
parties and bringing everyone in and
that's true across the board in civil
cases in new hampshire
i don't know if that answers your
question
mr cousins you have a better a
[Music]
closer to the question and answer closer
to the question yes ma'am
please thank you
um so right now a
pardon me right now a physician
assistant
uh can be sued for the care they
provided
when a physician assistant is sued
the physician that is on that what
currently is that rsp form
can also be sued simply because
their name is on that form even if they
had nothing to do with the care that was
provided um
a pa would not be involved in performing
surgery necessarily but i'll for
simplicity's sake madam chair if you
will um
say a pa sees someone at a urgent care
center because they have a strep throat
um and for some reason uh and and
there's no reason for the pa they they
look at the throat they get they confirm
it with strep they provide the
antibiotics and that's it a fairly
straightforward interaction the pa does
not need to consult with anyone on the
care of that um
but that that patient sues
they could certainly sue the pa they can
also sue the physician who is the
responsible supervisory physician for
that pa right now
even though that that physician had
nothing to do with this basic
interaction so what we're saying in this
bill is
that that may not make sense
and so what we're saying is that
physician should no longer
be able to be sued if they had
absolutely nothing to do with the case
just because their name is on a piece of
paper the pa absolutely still will be
sued
what the bill makes clear though is that
if there was any kind of
involvement from
that supervisory physician or any
physician for that matter
if they simply ask the question said
geez you know i do see a little of this
as i look down their throat
right there right then now that brings
liability upon the physician and so
we're making we're just making clear
that just because your name is on a
piece of paper you don't get sued but if
you have anything to do with the care of
that provider you absolutely still are
liable for um in that instance
pas pas don't lose their
don't lose their liability
that they have now under this bill
thank you very much for the explanation
all right and
yes representative schmidt
representative allegro
does the physician
not have to do with that
error
or damage
if they hired that physician's assistant
no no i think you know that's and
correct me if i'm wrong but
you know these uh any malpractice type
situation is
uh is determined based on that
interaction
i suppose
if
you're talking about a private uh a
private practice
then if there were a lawsuit of some
sort i'm sure that the practice itself
would be would be named in a suit but um
if you're talking about let's just say
someone goes to
um
the elliot to one of their urgent care
centers and they see a pa
um
then
but but the the physician who is the the
responsible supervising physician or in
this case the collaborating physician of
this bill they have nothing to do with
the care under the scenario i um painted
for representative fellows
they would not that physician would not
be sued but i'm sure that the elliot as
the employer of the pa
would be um would be part of the lawsuit
that's that's just
speculation i think we're all
speculating a lot about lawsuits
so i would
yes representative o'brien thank you
madam chair i don't care about lawsuits
but
what i hear here from your explanation
you know as a deputy my former job as a
deputy fire chief i used to read the
reports and just to make sure that
everything was adequate that the
companies were
behaving within the training and
procedures
by eliminating this
uh
in other words no physicians got to
review and say oh i think you might have
got this wrong reading the report you
should probably call the patient back is
is that eliminating that
a supervisory look at it a second
like a doctor overseeing
thank you for the question
representative this bill does not change
anything in terms of how
a physician
and a pa interact it doesn't change
how a an employer would require a pa in
a physician to act
other questions
representative schmidt
do we have further witnesses
[Music]
no
we have that's the last pin card we have
i'm going to ask
i'm going to ask if anyone else wishes
to speak but we've already spent
more time than anticipated on this so
unless you have a serious question
do you no okay thank you
i'll representative goalie
thank you madam chair i was hoping there
would be someone else coming up but i
will ask
to
i guess mr cousy
um
on here it struck
that the individual must maintain
current national certification if
required by a national certifying body
um why was that struck and is that no
longer applicable do they not belong to
any national certification uh
they i i don't have the the bill in
front of me but those were what the bill
was looking to do was remove entities
that or references to certifications uh
that do not exist and that would be uh
that would be a situation
um
there as um as i heard it as you know as
i'm remembering what's in the bill
i i if i can just grab my copy behind me
on page 2
line 27.
yeah there are no national there is no
national certification
um that exists and that's why that was
that's why that was struck
any other questions
okay thank you very much thank you madam
chair if i may i do i just want to
clarify um
i do not believe that anybody has ever
been sued for misdiagnosing strep throat
in the state of new hampshire and i will
be following up with the committee with
some information that's hopefully
helpful and then you'll have my email
address and please feel free to send me
any questions thank you very much for
that additional
representative schmidt
i don't believe you indicated it whether
your associate whether your
organization is in support of this bill
or you're testifying she said that they
are neutral
you are in support thank you
representative schmidt they are neutral
yes thank you they are neutral they are
not in support they are neutral
that's what i said yes
okay is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 228
okay seeing none i'm going to close the
hearing open the hearing on senate bill
and call peter o'neil for senator
hennessy
good morning madam chair and members of
the edna committee my name is peter
o'neil for the record and i am the
legislative aide for senator erin
hennessey from district one
unfortunately she cannot be here today
and thanks you all for the courtesy of
letting me introduce her bill
on her behalf
so last year the legislature took a
close look at the emergency orders
issued during the pandemic to see which
should be codified into law when the
state of emergency lapsed the result was
senate bill 155 which among other
provisions extending the temporary
health partners program and gave the
office of professional licensure and
certification to issue emergency
licenses to in-demand medical providers
that authority and those licenses should
have expired on january 31st
but the oplc was able to go through
rules for a short-term extension senate
bill 277 simply changes the date until
which the oplc can issue licenses from
january 31st 2022 to january 31st 2024
since the beginning of the pandemic 22
000 individuals not previously licensed
in new hampshire have been granted
emergency licensing status this program
is working we should extend it two more
years and give the next legislature time
to consider this streamlined licensing
authority should be repealed extended or
made permanent we all know how important
this has been for the state of new
hampshire given how difficult it has
been to find health care providers in
these times if you have any questions
for senator hennessey i can make sure
she gets you an answer but i would
largely defer to oplc and the health
care providers here in support of this
bill senator hennessey thank you for
your consideration and support of senate
bill 277 thank you very much for your
time
thank you um i believe
i don't think we'll have any questions
at this point so
but we we will reserve the right to uh
communicate with you if we do thank you
very much madam chair
kate horrigan
good morning madam chair my name is kate
horgan i serve as the executive director
for the new hampshire association of
counties which is all of your elected
and appointed officials this bill is
very simple as peter explained it puts
temporary health care licenses into the
statute for another two years
temporary health care partners
in our county nursing homes have been
vital as we continue to work through our
workforce shortage and we would urge the
committee to
support the bill
and i'm sure oplc will have lots more
detailed answers for you but i'm happy
to take any questions that you have
which professions are getting these
emergency and temporary licenses uh so
it's
i'm sure oplc can tell you all of them
um so i would direct it to them but i do
know that they are working in the
nursing homes
another question
thank you
good morning
for the record my name is jessica
calipalitas i'm the director of the
division of enforcement at the office of
professional licensure and certification
um i am here on behalf of oplc
and oplc does support the language of
senate bill 277
our executive director lindsay courtney
provided written testimony which
provides greater detail which i'm i'm
not going to repeat here for you
but um i would be happy to answer any
questions that the committee might have
thank you are there are there questions
represent goalie
thank you madam chair
why why do they feel the need to take it
out to 2024
um
i'm not
exactly certain i could of why it was
taken out two years why it was that
length of time i can certainly follow up
with the executive director and get back
to you on that
thank you it is two years from 2022 to
2024.
yes
yes thank you uh
representative allegro
thank you madam chair um i just want to
make sure i'm not misunderstanding what
i'm i expect is actually a simple
concept here
um
right now there's a temporary
situation
that was triggered by the declaration of
a state of emergency
that arrangement is set to expire
and the goal here is to extend it for
two years and so my question is since
you've answered the first ones with nods
the my question is is
why not seek to make it permanent now
based upon
a subsequent declaration of an emergency
i'd like a little insight thank you
um certainly i can i can attempt to
answer that to the best of my ability i
may have to follow up on that one as
well um but my understanding is that
although
healthcare workers who had these
temporary licenses had the opportunity
to seek full licensure many of them did
not there is a concern that if
those licenses are to expire and are not
extended that that would have a negative
impact on
the workforce in health care in new
hampshire
so that may be partially
why it was looking look too extended why
or look to be extended because they can
seek full licensure but many of them
have not for various reasons
um
but again i can follow up with the
executive director to get a more
detailed response to you
on that that's what concerns me is
that
we had a separate bill to
consider the qualifications of people
who are getting these license
and i'm very concerned that there are
people who are actually
not applying for a permanent license
because they wouldn't qualify
and i don't know
if we want to do that
also i'm very concerned that you're
talking about
online eight you're
you're applying this retroactively
and i don't believe that's
constitutionally allowable
right
other questions
represent goalie
thank you ma'am chair
um i'm also looking at um on
the first page on line
13 down through as to why are we
not charging a fee for a male and
pharmacy license why is it at no cost
i apologize i'm going to have to follow
up on that as well um i i don't know why
there's no cost it may have
simply been part of the emergency
process to get it in place quickly
that would be extended but i will follow
up and get you a better answer on that
thank you because if we're going to
extend this for almost two years i think
they should be paying
i would tend to agree
since that's a fairly hefty license fee
i take it that none of the individuals
who applied for these these licenses
paid any kind of a fee
i don't know if there was a fee um
i apologize i don't
okay thank you yep
yes representative pearson thank you
as as we've
worked our way through the coba 19
pandemic
and as we've discussed both in this
committee and as a legislative body
we have
different i guess opinions on what
constitutes emergency
action versus management
um
i would argue we are well into the
management phase
of this
so
from a management standpoint
oplc certainly
and this is a question i would i would
presume has the
kind of the management of all this kind
of down pat
by now
um are you referring to the
administrative processes involved in
issuing i'm referring to the
administrative processes of these
emergency provisions that were put into
place
during the emergency phase of the covet
19 pandemic so
yes
so you've kind of got this down
you're chugging along in other words
okay
other questions representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh uh you
you've been put into somewhat
uh difficult situation here
testifying on behalf of uh
oplc uh is this uh bill going to have
some kind of a subcommittee so that we
can have
sorry uh
see you from where i'm sitting so that
we can have
access to the executive director who has
the authority in this matter and
probably uh
uh
uh ought to be testifying before us
i don't know it certainly appears to be
much less straightforward than i thought
when i first read the bill
and
i think it's pretty straightforward in
one respect but probably not going to
meet with much approval on the part of
the committee uh given the fact that
there are questions that have already
been raised uh that need answers and
scholar pelegis is not in a position to
provide those answers yes good point
representative goalie thank you madam
chair and i just want to state my
concern as well um especially in if you
look at the numbers and the fiscal note
fiscal year 2022 a loss of almost 700
000 in license revenue is a concern
yes i mean i i would suggest that some
of the people that did not apply to
permanent license looked at the license
fee and said
why bother i can get a free license
so um
that's it
i suppose fourth yes exactly
representative fellows
um i i don't know if you know the answer
to this or not i'm just wondering if the
license for the pharmacies that's being
extended
would have um if that has
the that emergency licensing has
anything to do with the availability of
the covered vaccinations vaccines
my understanding is that it does not my
understanding of the
the permits for the pharmacies has to do
with clinical trial participants who
would get the clinical trial drugs from
a location in massachusetts that would
be an out of state pharmacy but they're
unable to travel there so it would allow
them to
still have access to those
those drugs
thank you
thank you i think representative
yakubovic
your subcommittee should at least meet
and discuss this possibly with some of
the when we get the questions answered
are there any other questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony
is there any is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on senate bill 277
okay seeing none i will close the
hearing
and
yes representative billy
um we did receive a letter from director
courtney um so if anyone wants to take a
look at it you should have it and it
tells a little bit about the
emergency order for
pharmacies
okay well thank you that's helpful
all right
we have a few minutes before our next
hearing so we'll take
there was some written testimony passed
out by miss horgan
but there weren't enough copies for all
the members at least they didn't get
over here
you
being 11 15
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
284 and calling senator ward
good morning madam chair
and members of the committee
for the record i'm ruth ward senator for
the district 8
and i'm here today to present to you
senate bill 284
which is a request of the new hampshire
optometric association which represents
over 180 doctors of optometry in new
hampshire
unlike other similar doctorate level
independently practicing health
providers the optimist
optometrists
so-called scopa practice and the
diseases that treat is dictated by
statute
current status relative to treatment of
glaucoma was put in place in 2002
and authorizes treatment of primary open
angle glaucoma
glaucoma is a disorder of the eye
characterized by increased intraocular
pressure that may cause impaired vision
ranging from slight loss to absolute
blindness
much has changed since 2002 including
the statues in most states new hampshire
is the only one of three states that do
not allow treatment for all glaucomas by
optometrists
senate bill 284 will amend the statute
to allow optometrists who are certified
by the state board to treat all
glaucomas
this has the benefit to patients who no
longer will need a referral with
separate health care professional to
treatment of a disease that the
optometrist is perfectly capable of
treating
it will also ensure that top-notch
optometrists will practice in new
hampshire rather than another state
where they may practice to the fullest
extent of the education and
training this bill makes two other
related changes to the glaucoma statute
that the optometrist here will provide
details on
i know optometrists today are educated
well-trained and capable of treating new
hampshire patients as this bill allows
and i ask the committee to recommend
ought to pass on this common sense
legislation thank you
thank you senator are there any
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
okay
uh alison wranger
you gave it you indicated you have
written testimony have you sent that to
us previously
[Music]
thank you very much
no problem
okay
are we all set okay well my name is dr
allison laranger i was born and raised
in bedford new hampshire i currently
live in goffstown
and practice full-time in manchester at
new hampshire eye associates
i started my career in rhode island in
2010 and then moved to my dream state
colorado
in 2012.
my parents health began to decline in
2019 so my priorities changed and i
moved back to my home state where i
intend to finish out my career it had
never crossed my mind that i'd be coming
home to a restrictive glaucoma law i
fully expected to practice optometry as
i had since graduating in 2010.
the reason i was so surprised was
because after graduation i learned it i
landed my first job at a private
practice in rhode island and started
treating glaucoma without restriction
i did not have to clear cases with other
providers or have anyone check my work
the same was true in colorado
i also treated secondary glaucomas in
both states from day one
in fact new hampshire has the most
restrictive glaucoma laws in new england
and is one of three states in the
country that cannot treat secondary
glaucomas
on top of that i learned that despite
having treated full scope glaucoma
independently for nine years and
studying it extensively in optometry
school
i was required to consult with an
ophthalmologist for all new glaucoma
cases for a full two years after
receiving my new hampshire license
and since every glaucoma patient was
technically new to me the
ophthalmologists in my practice were
burdened with having to review every
single glaucoma patient that i saw
this is the same for every doctor moving
to this state or new licensee in general
since every glaucoma patient is new to
them
this rule is outdated and is not in line
with our modern education and the length
of time that optometrists have been
treating glaucoma
in the state and around the country
optometrists have been treating glaucoma
for more than 20 years
optometrists are doctorate level
providers with independent licenses to
practice and we do not and we're not
required to be monitored or have
sign-offs for anything else that we do
we have prescriptive authority for oral
and topical medications including
controlled substances we order mris ct
scans ultrasounds stroke workups blood
work etc
i needed to come home to new hampshire
for the sake of my family
but a lot of optometrists have a choice
of where they want to practice and it
makes sense that when choosing a job
they will weigh new hampshire's current
restrictions versus the ability to treat
glaucoma
fully to their level of education and
training
passing this bill will undoubtedly open
new hampshire to more candidates for the
health care system and more top-notch
eye care providers for the community
and that is all i have for today but i
want to thank you so much for listening
to me and for serving our state
and i ask that you please support state
bill 284 to bring our laws into
alignment with our modern training
and the rest of the country
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
amazing thank you very much
we need sang
madam chairman members of the committee
i'm dr winnie sang i'm an optometrist
and have been in practice in new
hampshire for over 20 years
i'm one of the owners of a group
practice in littleton
woodsville and lincoln
i am here to give you some of my
insights
through another set of optics with
regards to sb 284
being in the north country and in a
rural setting our practice is the go-to
practice for primary and medical eye
care
to our communities we treat a myriad of
eye conditions and diseases including
glaucoma
but for many years i did not have the
authority to treat glaucoma
independently because i graduated in
2001.
if i may ask you to refer to page 1
lines 12-13
those line items pertain to me
and some of my colleagues who graduated
before 2002
as you know
under the current statute optometrists
who graduated prior to 2002 have to go
through a tedious and logistically
difficult process
of obtaining therapeutic glaucoma
certification
to clarify the context of my testimony
please refer to page 1 lines 24-28
and page 2
lines 3-4
as referred in those lines
i had to have 25 cases of only one
particular type of glaucoma that i had
to have my fellow ophthalmologists
co-manage with me
our patients in the north country would
travel one to two hours to meet an
ophthalmologist face to face for a set
period of time to prove co-management of
these cases have been reviewed by the
ophthalmologist
and these cases had to be for only one
type of glaucoma
primary open-angle glaucoma
and as you may know
there are many types of glaucoma we have
been trained to treat
but we could not use the other types of
glaucoma in our cases
for the certification process
this is one of the reasons it took me
many years to attain certification
status
other reasons were micromanaging
ophthalmologists retired
and then another one relocated
and on occasions
patients relocated in which case i had
to start over again
it was a process that was unnecessary to
not just me
but to the patients i served
because a number of them did not want to
see another eye doctor
for providing the same care i provided
for them
i actually contemplated moving to
another state in the beginning of this
process
because if i were practicing in almost
all other states of the country
i would be able to treat glaucoma
independently
regardless of when i graduated
as i was academically and clinically
trained to
do it's ironic to note
the associates in my practice who
graduated later than i did
in 2002 onward
with the same education i received
were able to independently treat
glaucoma without the restrictions i had
needless to say those restrictions
impeded not only access to quality of
care to our patients
but timely quality eye care
since i had to co-manage with a
sponsoring ophthalmologist
and due to the fact there are only a
couple of ophthalmologists in our neck
of the woods
the limited number of ophthalmologists
means patients had to wait
sometimes too long
for a co-management
appointment with another eye doctor who
would be managing these glaucoma cases
the exact same way
i was managing them
these duplicative care scenarios are
inefficient to our health care system
and more importantly
it does a disservice to our patients as
we fail to provide a timely access to
care
you may ask
how will sb 284 benefit the patients
sb284 would take away the burden on our
patients and that they will be provided
with a timely
quality eye care that would be
sustainable to our health care system
if co-management is needed with an
ophthalmologist like in my experience
a face-to-face encounter is not
mandatory
this is especially helpful for our rural
patients who are not eager to travel
hours to get duplicative care
sb284 is a patient-centric
modernized bill that would ensure we are
reaching closer and closer to our goal
on preserving the eyesight of our
glaucoma patients
because there is going to be quality eye
care that is easily accessible for the
citizens of new hampshire
by increasing access to care to highly
trained and qualified optometrists
patients will be reassured their local
eye doctors are ready to provide them
with the highest quality eye care they
deserve
without the burden of long travel and
wait times
i thank you for your consideration okay
will you answer some questions
sure
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so doctor uh
can you tell me or estimate what
percentage of
i'm over here ma'am to your left oh i'm
sorry
right over here
um
thank you
so can you estimate what percentage of
the overall patient population that you
might have been able to uh to serve
but
without restriction had the law
permitted it uh
what what reduction in
uh in
uh ability to to provide the totality of
service that you should have been able
to prevent pres present
provide
um as a
against what you actually had to do
because you had to
get an ophthalmologist involved
and
reschedule and go through the whole
other rigmarole you described in your
written testimony i hope you you've
already provided it thank you can you so
you can you give us an estimate of what
kind of loss to your pr to your practice
you experience as a result of the
current situation
that still exists
thank you for your question
um
what i see is it's not a loss to our
practice
it's more
a loss to the patient's um
wait time and the care that they could
have gotten
you know had they gotten access to care
right now the wait time to see a fellow
ophthalmologist for co-management is
more than
you know it could be more than six
months in some cases in dartmouth
and around our neck of the woods there's
you know only a couple ophthalmologists
i could um access that kind of
co-management with
thank
you thank you madam chair uh thank you
dr k could you just briefly give us um
an idea of the
timeliness that's necessary to do
treatments
such as you're talking about
sure i would i'd like to uh answer that
question um
so
the the kind of glaucoma that we see are
a myriad of glaucomas you know there are
some types of glaucoma that require
urgent treatment
you know we cannot wait six months
depending on the stage of glaucoma that
a patient may encounter
and so every case is different
but
you know we always want to think about
preserving people's vision and their
eyesight and the you know the timelier
care they can get and
you know in the care that days are
they deserve the better and you know if
just think of it as if it were your
mother or your sister
and you know they had just been
diagnosed with glaucoma
and you can't at this point manage it
without them seeing anybody
you know it may not be
um an emergency situation where you they
had to come
and get care within a day
but in their mind you know they they're
already diagnosed for glaucoma and they
want that treatment as soon as possible
and as i would if i were a patient and i
was just diagnosed with a condition that
could be vision threatening
okay thank you representative scitec um
what's the truth what will
you're referring someone to an
ophthalmologist let's say you are doing
glaucoma treatment and the pressures
don't go down or if something goes wrong
when do you
it is specified in the bill
is there any other questions
representative bailey
thank you madam chair um
so the part that would allow a 2001
graduate or before to proceed is this
bolded line that says you're instead
certified by the american board of
optometry that's what it would allow
that's the fix
um would you
mind clarifying that question line 15 of
page one
it mentions the 2002. you said you were
a 2001 graduate you had all these
problems
right see that the jump start for not
having that problem is 2002
and they've added
or who are certified by the american
board of optometry
that's the fix is it
so yes well
we now have you know american brought up
optometrists who are
certified as fellow optometrists
and you know having that fellowship
status
means that they have you know extra
continuing education that would allow
them to be able to treat glaucoma
and and i am one of those optometrists
thank you
representative judy and then marsh yes
thank you madam chair
good morning doctor good morning um
right now how you
allowed to do surgery
no we are not
we are not trained for surgery we are
primary care optometrists
we treat glaucoma medically
but we are not surgeons
in the you know definition of surgery in
the new hampshire statute
all right thank you
representative
thank you madam chair this is a
follow-up to the earlier question the
certification by the american board of
optometry on page 1 lines 15-16 is that
certificate time limited or is it given
for lifetime
the certification process is given to a
lifetime however
we are obligated to go through a
continuing education process you know
there are a minimum of hours that we
need to attain every year to regain our
license sure
does that answer your question sir thank
you
i have a question
um actually it might be
applied to the other one it says that
it looks as though current statute says
the board may waive these requirements
for someone who
was licensed and practiced for at least
a year
is the board actually not waiving those
requirements
i may
answer that question oh please yes
you've got someone else okay
okay thank you i wasn't sure who would
it would answer it thank you i'll love
the postponement any other questions
representative pearson thank you madam
chair um just curious as to what
magically happened in 2002 to put a line
in the sand between
those
prior and those after
and so that's the year i graduated in
2001 and interestingly enough soon after
i graduated we had a bill on glaucoma
that you know uh
gave a scope expansion to optometrist to
be able to treat primary
angle glaucoma that but that would
happen after that year the bill was
passed
okay that that no that's um that's not
really what i asked
from a let me rephrase it from a
let's call it an educational sense
was there a significant difference in
the curriculum
that one would go through in 2002 that
changed
why is this date in here i see i see
your question thank you for clarifying
that
there is no difference in education uh
you know
someone who graduated in 2001 like
myself has the same education as someone
who graduated a year later in 2002
so it was you know just one of those
lines that they made when they
passed
the statute
makes no sense to that okay
other questions
seeing none thank you very much
uh
ms uh
pitchmoth
dr hitchcock yes
since we have an open question
good morning thank you for letting me uh
talk to all of you and thank you for
your service um through the last couple
years which has been more difficult than
usual i think
can you hear me okay now that's better
okay great i appreciate that uh dr
dorothy hitch moth i practice in new
london new hampshire i've been
practicing in the state for over 25
years
i'm obviously here representing the new
hampshire optometric association i'm
also on the board of trustees at the new
england college of optometry and can
answer any questions about education i
was also present for all of the
negotiations if you want to call them
that when the bill was originally passed
both uh in 2002 and prior
so i will answer your question hopefully
more directly and say
that i agree with you it makes no sense
um and as all of you know that when
legislative compromises occur they often
make no sense so um the training
of doctors of optometry really hasn't
changed since before i graduated which
is a lot longer ago
and
i will affirm that
there were many many states already in
the country that allowed full scope of
practice in regard to the treatment of
glaucoma which is a single eye disease
by the way
happens to be a sight threatening eye
disease
so even in 2002
so we were already behind the eight ball
at that time and i was physically
present for all of those negotiations
and will tell you that the only way that
we were able to compromise and pass the
bill at that time was to allow for this
secondary process
to be implemented and that secondary
process is what you're reading in those
long two pages in front of you
so
for those individuals those doctors who
had graduated who had not served for a
year or did a residency for a year or
served in the department of veterans
affairs for a year would have to go
through another iterative process
because there was concern
that there were all these doctors
running around that somehow didn't have
modernized training despite the
requirements for ongoing competency and
ongoing education through our usual
processes
so
in order to
allay the fears potentially of those of
you who have to make difficult decisions
about scope of practice which is a whole
other issue in and of itself that was
the compromise with this bill the
essence of this bill is to remove some
of those old restrictions
we are suffering in the north country i
will tell you it is very very difficult
to recruit doctors we have an access
problem
there are two of us in my area and
nobody for a 60 mile radius the dock up
the street from me has a one year wait
list for just regular eye care
i'll be i won't speak on behalf of my
friends in ophthalmology but you know i
have cataract surgeons that just simply
don't have the time to see these
patients when that opportunity or when
that has to occur
you know they're booked out weeks and
weeks dartmouth the wait time is months
for cataract surgery for example so
we're injecting redundancy into the
system
that is just not necessary and that's
really what this bill is asking for is
to let's please eliminate the redundancy
especially in a state where we have so
many rural areas
with a perfectly qualified and educated
group of doctors who have an amazing
track record already specifically in
this state and amazingly so across the
country and treating this one particular
disease group i'll tell you there are
more types of glaucoma this bill bill
specifically addresses what we call
secondary glaucomas which means that
those cases are somewhat more rare
possibly more
calcitrant to treatment and may need
surgical referral but do we i don't
think we need to legislate those types
of things
these are things that happen naturally
between referring providers if you're
competent
if there's an assumption of incompetence
well that's a different problem
so i hope i've answered a few of the
questions i will also add that i was at
the department of veterans affairs for
22 years that served the two northern
counties in new hampshire
and treated full scope
many many many veterans who i put on a
much
who who i have ultimate respect for and
think we need to maintain the integrity
of their health care system for a whole
host of other reasons but there were no
restrictions to this effect um on those
veterans
yes thank you my specific question was
that it looks as though on page 2 line
it says that the committee may waiver
reduce these requirements
for people
who have a license and proof of practice
for 12 months in another state in
another set but dr larander said that
she had practiced nine years in another
state and still was not this was not
waived so for her it was wave if i'm not
mistaken
yeah so i believe it what so there were
a whole host of doctors who met by
statute the waiver i was one of them
right so i was
treating for years and years and so i
didn't have to go through this
uh
process however there's still even for
those of us who have had the waivers
there's still restrictions in the
language that say you need to refer for
a certain time period which is onerous
and nearly impossible um especially i
understand that i just i was just
concerned that the
certification committee or credentialing
committee was
not accepting out-of-state practice
because it says may and in many cases
we've had concerns with that sure
thank you representative pearson
thank you madam chair
and i uh
i greatly appreciate you coming
before us with your especially with your
historical perspective on how we got to
this um
does this i two two things are you
confident that this is going to
accomplish what it's intended to do
first off
yes this will expand the number of
doctors that we have that will not have
to refer based on the way the language
is written right now do i think that
there are some other unintended
consequences no
okay and secondly is there a simpler way
to do this or is this kind of just the
way you got to pave this road
i think this is the way that we have to
pave this road this road we one thing
that we didn't want to do as an
association
is go back
and
make it look like we were trying to
expand our current scope of practice
because as you all know that's
a little more difficult pathway so we
didn't want to have to sacrifice patient
care and access and we thought this was
really the most simple way to do it was
to just adjust the language as it's
written
okay representative schmidt
representative pearson has asked my
question
how efficient are there any other
questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much yeah thank you
christine donahue
good morning madam chair members of the
committee before i get into my prepared
speech i do serve on the joint
credentialing committee so i thought
maybe i could speak to the waiver
situation for a moment
regarding dr laranger's practice in a
different state that had unrestricted
privileges
and
we are definitely granting waivers
however as of now the only thing that we
can waiver is the initial certification
process of the 25 co-managed cases
we are not able to uh do a waiver for
the period after certification that
every optometrist in the state
regardless of year of graduation or
regardless of
that if they've been practicing for 20
years in rhode island we are not
able to waive the 24 month requirement
where they still have to refer
every single new case of glaucoma
so it's really a
two-tiered
approach to how you get your glaucoma
certification you do the 25 cases if you
were prior to 2002
that can be waived if you are practicing
elsewhere what cannot be waived again
every optometrist once they get that
certification has to still co-manage for
24 months
regardless if they graduated last year
from optometry school
does that clear that up for you
yes thank you very much
so that that
lines 22 and 23 are the issues that they
that is correct and okay thank you very
much thank you
so
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today in support of senate bill
284 this bill seeks to reduce
unnecessary restrictions on the
treatment of glaucoma by doctors of
optometry in new hampshire again my name
is dr christine kaben donahue and i am
also a lifelong resident of bedford new
hampshire since 2009 i have been
practicing optometry at manchester eye
in manchester new hampshire i do
currently serve as the newest member on
the new hampshire board of optometry but
i'm here today on my own behalf
manchester eye associates was first
started back in 1977 by my dad dr david
cavan and i am proud to be a second
generation optometrist in our state and
feel as though i've spent basically my
whole life in the fields i also remember
my father
attending many proceedings when the
current glaucoma statute was passed in
2002 so 20 years later it is my
privilege to be part of this well-known
update
to the statute
during my professional career i have
treated a large number of patients with
glaucoma i know it's been touched upon
but glaucoma is a disease in which
progressive damage to the optic nerve
can result in permanent vision loss
about 3 million americans have glaucoma
and worldwide it is still the second
leading cause of blindness in the world
it is very treatable but has no symptoms
often so early detection and treatment
are critical
when glaucoma was added to the optometry
statute over 20 years ago treatment was
specifically restricted to the single
type of glaucoma which we refer to as
primary open angle glaucoma it is also
the most common primary open angle has
no identifiable cause and is
characterized by damage to the optic
nerve from really many factors but
probably the best known as high eye
pressure
however there are many other common
types of glaucoma including low pressure
glaucoma glaucoma caused by abnormal
ocular conditions inocular inflammation
glaucoma caused by medication use and
glaucoma caused by injury these other
forms of glaucoma are within the
training and treatment capability of
doctors of optometry using the same
methods of treatment that we currently
use for primary open angle glaucoma
for the 13 years that i have been
treating glaucoma although i have had
the training the ability and the tools
to treat these other forms i have been
restricted from doing so
in these cases i must have my patient
receive their treatment from the
ophthalmologist this is unnecessary
inefficient redundant not cost effective
and burdensome burdensome to the patient
and to the provider
further we have rural areas in our state
without sufficient supply of
ophthalmologists to treat the conditions
a friend of mine dr angel sawyer who
practices in north conway reports that
due to the lack of other providers in
the area or those who would travel to
the north country her patients are
traveling an hour or two for their care
when she is ready willing and able to
treat them herself
unfortunately the statute is preventing
her from doing so
these restrictions on the treatment of
glaucoma by dr doctors of optometry put
in place over 20 years ago are outdated
and at this point unnecessary
in the past new hampshire was a
desirable place for practicing optometry
as it was considered to have a pretty
good scope of practice however with
legislative advantages advances excuse
me in other states new hampshire now has
one of the most restrictive glaucoma
treatment statutes in the country in
addition to these restrictions impacting
us as eye care providers and our
patients the restrictions make it
challenging to recruit and hire new
doctors to our state prospective
candidates are surprised to learn how
they would be restricted here in new
hampshire and some have chosen to
practice elsewhere
these restrictions limit our ability to
add to top-notch providers to our state
while i have discussed a good deal of
what senate bill 284 will change i'd
like to reiterate some of what it does
not change
there will continue to be requirements
for optometrists to consult in advanced
cases of glaucoma that are not
responding to treatment acute cases of
glaucoma that require prompt laser
intervention
or cases of glaucoma in those
under the age of 18. it is important to
note that we have had detailed
discussions with the leadership of new
hampshire's ophthalmologists regarding
this bill
and what you have before you is language
that includes compromises resulting from
those discussions senate bill 284 as
submitted is language that was agreeable
to leadership of both optometry and
ophthalmology
in summary senate bill 284 will remove
unnecessary restrictions on the
optometric treatment of glaucoma to the
benefit of our patients our colleagues
and to the new hampshire health care
system thank you for your time and
consideration
thank you very much are there any
questions representative
this is that this is actually a question
for senator ward was there any
opposition in the senate to this bill
there is not that we know of
no
represent uh representative fellows
uh thank you thank you on
page
line 18
is a reference to
therapeutic pharmaceutical agent
certified
optometrist is that
a separate certification or would
everybody
so it is separate
prior to 1980
something if you graduated before that
before
therapeutic
topical agents were
added to the statute which i believe was
some
point in the 80s
that was its own licensure i don't
actually know that there are
really any optometrists in the state
practicing
there are none left
follow-up so
that would mean we probably could take
that out of the statute
um
i'm not sure as our license is still
written that way
that you're a therapeutic
optometrist
a tpa
certified
we would have we could look into that
it may not be as simple as changing that
paragraph but yes it's something to
consider if we work on amendments
uh any other question representative
goalie
thank you madam chair
why is it taking 20 years to get here
that is a very good question
i'm not sure i've been practicing for 13
years it's certainly been on my radar um
the whole time
but
i think that
some of us now um you know there's no
better time than now so here we are yeah
yes thank you representative bailey
hi
thank you
going back to that date i mean on line
13 page one
would the world end if it just said
graduated instead of graduated after
2002. so i think that was the year that
this was passed so i think you know the
original statute so i think what they
decided was okay from this point on you
know this is what we're doing and from
this point before
this is what we're doing that was 20
years ago what would happen if now we
just scratched out after 2002
would that
cause chaos
representative bailey will take it as
another case where this statute could
use some
uh fine tooth combing to straighten it
up but thank you i i think that is the
case representing goalie you have no
anyone else
and what yes representative schmidt
the effective date is 60 days after its
passage
uh it is frequently the case that there
is some preparatory
action required of the state or agencies
or whatever so they can't put the
statute into effect immediately because
first you have to have
you know step one before you can you
have to build a basement before you can
build the first floor right
is there any reason why we couldn't have
an effective date that would be more
immediate and relieve our optometrists
and our north country
population of the
stupidness
of this current situation
uh
sooner than 60 days i'm sure we could
work on that yes i'm sure if it was
agreeable we could reluctant
any changes that would make it have to
go back to the senate that's it that
would be that would
the only thing that would make me
hesitate and if that was not the case
then we could you know certainly
consider speeding it up but i'm not sure
about the ramifications of of it
okay we'll weigh that thank you
very good any other questions represent
pete you've got representative bailey
anyone else
represent judy yes please thank you
madam chair
good morning doctor thank you uh
how many years
someone has to study to become
an ophthalmologist and also optometrist
so for an optometrist we complete four
years of undergraduate study graduating
with a degree often in pre-med by uh
mine was biology
and then it's four years of optometry
school after that year-round
you graduate past the national board
exams you may also choose to become a
specialist which there's residencies
available year or two residencies
ophthalmologists go to medical school
graduate decide they want to become an
ophthalmologist and then they specialize
in eye care
after that completing a surgical
fellowship this bill
is not really highlighting
those differences are touching um on
educational
requirements or training um however um
there is
as you appreciate a lot of overlap
between the two professions and um this
bill has been discussed
by both professions and there is no
opposition so i think it's a good
stepping stone for all of us
yes thank you other questions thank
you all right
thank you very much thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 284
represent senator reagan before you
dismissed your committee for lunch i did
something
uh
nothing to do with this bill okay in
that case
i will close the hearing on senate bill
284 and recognize senator
reagan's back and forth with the board
of acupuncture yeah
and they promised me that they will
draft
but through their attorney
as a place all about
thank you
well our actually center we have
a bill that we have an interim study
that we were quite far along that we
might just replace all
we appreciate that
okay uh in that case we are breaking for
lunch
uh senator reagan assures us that
uh senate bill 282 is not
he's not happy with the current
condition and therefore it may not be
ready
for us so if we don't come back on time
we'll start late
all right happy
lunch how to dance
i
you
i'm jack i'm representative jackie grota
i represent the hearing first
i appreciate your eagerness
all right it being one o'clock i'm
opening the hearing on senate bill 282
and i call
representative broder to introduce it
thank you madam chair i'm representative
jackie grota
representing the towns of ryan newcastle
rockingham district 24 and i'm here to
introduce senate bill 282
regarding acupuncture
thank you
all right i will
mention
that
the intent is for
this bill to go to representative leckus
and his subcommittee
and they will
re review it in the context of house
bill i think it's 1192 that dealt with
the same topic
and um
and fix any issues that may remain
okay
and
elizabeth rob
hi i'm elizabeth rob i'm
testifying for
amending sb 282 hb 1192
i was in front of this committee a
couple months ago
and i submitted about
11 or 12 letters from licensed
acupuncturists in new hampshire outside
of new hampshire
for
making the following changes to the
acupuncture practice act
so i just want to point out that the
licensing board wants to allow for
acupuncturists with a doctorate of
oriental medicine to call themselves
doctors and that's fine
but the changes that we're asking for
are allowing equivalent exams
like the california exam
in addition to the exam issued by
the national certification commission of
acupuncture and oriental medicine
remove the mandate that we have to pay
that same organization
to maintain active current status in
order to keep a license in the state of
new hampshire
it's redundant and burdensome and it's
not used in plenty of other states like
massachusetts where many
acupuncturists come from when they move
to new hampshire to get new hampshire
licenses
most of my co-workers actually
and to give the licensing board term
limits so in the five years ago there
were two members on the board who
finally stepped down after serving for
20 years
it's a lot of gatekeeping
um so i'm resubmitting the letters from
there's a letter from my employer our
clinic has been short staffed since we
reopened from the pandemic
and we've been operating at limited
hours and it's hard to find people to
come work with us and we have to search
out of state because there's not a lot
of acupuncturists in new hampshire and
so that active current status with the
ncc aom is a barrier for people to get
new hampshire licenses
there's another letter from my long time
friend and colleague diana de joya she's
a very senior acupuncturist on cape cod
running a very successful clinic but as
she's getting older she wants to move to
new hampshire so she can be closer to
family in northern new england
and
she's great acupuncturist and maintains
a license in good standing in
massachusetts but she doesn't have the
current active status with ncc aom and
so that keeps her from moving to new
hampshire
and
another one of my 11 12 letters is from
our accountant he points out that the
ncc aom is a trade association and i do
have their financials
from a website that tracks nonprofits
they're actually listed as a business or
industry association not a certifying
body
and i pointed out before that their
chief operating officer cory ward cook
when she stepped down in 2019 her salary
was over a quarter of a million dollars
and by law in new hampshire we have to
pay them and keep active status with
them whether we want to or not whether
we feel like they represent us at the
national level level or not
um
and our accountant jefferson tickering
points out that
he was the chair of the accountancy
board and the reason why he stopped is
because he was term limited out after so
many terms
so that's my testimony and i'm gonna
just go ahead and oh representative like
is
thank you or a suggestion that is i
would suggest
i'll end up scheduling a subcommittee
work session
and i suggest everybody who's there's an
interest in this come with
suggested language and we can thrash
through it and hopefully this time get
everybody to agree
on one thing so okay excellent
the deadline for this bill is
the 28th so we'll probably be executing
it on the 25th
4th or 25th
thank you thank you
but
i hope there's hope there's no other
questions
okay laura cooley
hi i'm a licensed acupuncturist from
orford new hampshire
i'm an advocate for legislative
improvements in laws across the country
to unwarranted restrictions on practice
which only increase over the 30 years
i've been
passing laws
in the u.s
so we're just asking a couple very
direct things i believe we have had a
hearing on this already i believe we are
somewhat appraised
i just want to say in chinese medicine
one of the principles we talk about
and treat is stagnation
we'd like to get rid of the regulation
that enables stagnation in our
profession
and this bill puts in reciprocity if you
pass the bill we're asking you to pass
anybody from any other state with a
license can practice here automatically
right now the way the licensing board
has delineated things 28 states do not
meet our standards
massachusetts is one california is one
florida's one they all have lots more
regulation than we do on acupuncture
and in fact in five states there are 17
000 acupunctures that new hampshire
licensing board deems not safe enough to
practice here
after they've been practicing in other
states so that doesn't make sense to me
if
i think
i'm not sure how many states don't have
laws anymore i oklahoma's the only one i
know of
but we're really saying that nobody else
is practicing in another state can
practice here when they apply for a
license this means something to me
because it took me a year and a half to
get a license here it cost me seventeen
hundred dollars
so i would really like this law fixed
and i believe the amendments we
submitted originally represented lycus
you have them i have
everything in my grubby little hands yes
this is a different bill this is the
senate bill rather than the house bill
and
um
like i said the intent is to take the
work we did on the house bill
and and folded into this
great
so i don't need to say anything else is
that correct
sounds good to me is there anyone else
who are there any other questions from
the committee
all right seeing none thank you miss
cooley
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 282
give us a pink card and uh introduce
yourselves
can you hear me okay yes
hi my name is molly gendro of strafford
new hampshire
i'm here to share support of sb282 as a
licensed acupuncturist and a member a
board member of the new hampshire
acupuncture and asian medicine
association
our association represents the interest
of acupuncturists across the state and
i'm here on behalf of our membership
we held a meeting in early january to
gauge member support for sb 282
and we are unanimous in support of our
fellow colleagues that go above and
beyond the typical master's degree to
get their doctorate
most acupuncturists in the state
hold a master's degree from a four-year
graduate program and we agree that those
that go beyond the typical four years to
their get their doctorate should take on
the title of doctor
we are also in support of the changes
for the licensing board
this would streamline licensing renewal
and we had a discussion about the
supervision of acupuncture detox
specialists and shared our recommended
changes to the first draft of the bill
in january
as it is stated in the amended bill you
have before you we agree that
acupuncture should be supporting
acupuncture detox specialists and with
supervision
this bill will allow supervision to be
more flexible allowing for in-person or
virtual check-ins i pulled our
membership and was surprised that out of
those who responded no one had been
asked to supervise and there are a
number of people happy to volunteer
their time
i do have a list of those volunteers the
new hampshire acupuncture and asian
medicine association members are in full
support of this bill as it is presented
to you today and urge you to vote yes to
pass sb 282 and i would like to take a
moment to mention that our association
is a wealth of knowledge for acupuncture
chinese and asian medicine and we have
members that are current students and
members that fought for the first
licensing of acupuncture here in new
hampshire so please reach out to us if
you have any questions regarding
acupuncture or asian medicine and i'm
happy to answer your questions today
thank you for your time
thank you i please fill out a pink card
and give it to us
and if you can support the
uh subcommittee we would very much
appreciate it yes thank you
okay
is there anyone else
good afternoon everybody i'm cindy
terugetti
oh you just turned it off yeah the
reason you can't hear it you got to kind
of eat the microphone especially for the
folks that are watching this from
youtube okay how about now better
all right i'm cindy terugetti i am the
chair of the new hampshire acupuncture
licensing board and as you folks know
this bill senate bill 282 mirrors the
language in house bill 1192
those amendments that you see are from
the board of acupuncture licensing in
both of those bills so we're in
agreement with the amendments as they
are
the only additional thing that we had
hoped to do was
move away from the word oriental and
that was put into the statute back 20
years ago when it was first enacted
and so that word is a pejorative word
now
thought by many and we're trying to move
away from it as
many of the standard setters in our
profession are doing and so we suggested
moving it to the word asian instead
with the exception of there's a couple
of organizations in that statute that
are named who
have
not yet changed their name so one of
them was the ncc aom
nccom is the certifying body it i'm not
sure of their legal corporation status
but they are the
standards setter for competency
nationally for board-certifying
acupuncturists throughout the united
states
but they are still called the ncca om
for acupuncture and oriental medicine so
as it's written in the statute that
would have to stay as it is
there is another
body the accrediting body for schools
and colleges that teach
post-secondary acupuncture programs and
that is the aca
om it used to be om but they actually
have changed their name to the aca hm
which stands for
the accrediting commission for
acupuncture and herbal medicine so since
they have already changed their name we
thought it would be appropriate to
change it in our statute as well
so just that i was speaking with senator
reagan
about other amendments relating to to
continuing education
um
and what he suggested was that that we
just
give a get our get some
get a completed statute adoptable as a
replace all amendment um and so that
will be forthcoming for us and the
reason why we want to change what's
written in the statute about continuing
education
is actually to make it easier for
licensees to get their continuing ad
units
we had made an amendment
and
the way that was interpreted by our
board council was that it would look
like the only way that they could get
their continuing ed units would be if
they were through the ncc aom and that's
not what we wanted we want people to be
able to get their continuing ed units in
other ways so we'll be working on that
okay
thank you for that yeah it is
something that the
subcommittee will be looking at i hope
you will support
and
actually looks to me
if you look on page 2 line 30
but continuing education
it deletes two sentences
and adds one i think that you just
leave the first sentence as is and
simply delete the second sentence the
the suggestion that was made um by our
board council which i think is a good
idea is
pretty close to what you just said um
and what we thought we would do is say
um that they can use they can get their
continuing ed units but leave the number
of hours out and actually address that
rules
to expound upon the number of hours that
are required in the rules that that
doesn't really need to be in the statute
that's what our
that's what was suggested the other
um
i
that's a policy decision whether it's in
statute or in rule so we'll consider
your position
okay good
and he went works in black us yeah um
so i looked through both 1192 and 282
and the word um
oriental isn't in there other than in
the initials for that one organization
so are you asking for
changes elsewhere in the statutes
as opposed to just changes in the
current bills
so the word oriental actually appears
nine times throughout the entire statute
representative lacus so we were looking
to change that
all right thank you okay thank you up to
you
representative judy yes thank you madam
chair
as you are a chair of this organization
how many doctors we have here in new
hampshire doctors of
acupuncture i would have to ballpark it
and i i think there it's a growing
number but it's it's somewhere under
five right now it's a recently
established program the doctorate in
acupuncture so it's something that's new
and we just want to allow for
those people who've gone and gotten that
degree to be able to use the title
there's not many yet i would say under
five we have 153 licensees total
okay all right thank you thank you thank
you thank you other questions
yes representative allegro
thank you i'm just curious to know what
the
degree requirements are can you
summarize them in a minute
sure well for a licensed acupuncturist
you have to have
1905 hours and a master's degree
so there's different levels of
acupuncture providers in the state of
new hampshire
and the top level would be the doctoral
degree i don't know off the top of my
head how many hours that is but it's
above and beyond the master's degree
obviously so it goes doctoral and then
masters and then we have the acupuncture
detoxification specialists who
are required to have 30 hours of
classroom time and 40 hours of practice
time under the supervision of a licensed
acupuncturist
thank you
okay
representative bailey
thank you
the the analysis on the front of the
bill mentions what you mentioned that
you'd like to be able to use the title
doctor
but i don't see that anywhere in the
bill i've represented bailly
unfortunately the bill in your hand
only has page two oh pages one and three
have more detail all right
sorry about that thank you
i noticed that myself when i was looking
for it
the the copies that are over there just
today only have page two
those who had copies from previous times
have all three pages
not your fault
any other questions or concerns
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony okay thank you all is there it
yes
is there and do fill out a pink card
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 282
all right seeing none i will close the
public hearing
since that's going to do something
yeah take a break
yes looking for two pink parts yes
you've got yes i know they can one of
them is being filled out even as we
speak
yes they did
we're all set on those guys thank you
died in the sun
that's what happened
everybody forgot or they came up with
new requirements like combing the
statute for oriental or whatever
yes thank you that'll help
oh no you didn't
i did emails just believe it or not
uh it's i haven't looked at my email
later
i've just
i don't know
but i didn't do it
that's my only book
that monday i will she's getting her
that's the plumbing details but she's
got a greater uh
david hitchcock for it okay
get that if you want to
but
she pointed out
there you go
one o'clock
something
okay
um
is
and then this is
i
never
that something's actually going out
because
and
um
to 1192 to make it the same
unanimously
that's right
[Music]
they
so for someone
um
make
okay
just change the part
yes
anyway
okay
take a look at it
is
um
that's your composer
all right i'm opening the hearing on
senate bill 330 and i call senator guida
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record bob geider
senate district 2.
and prime sponsor of senate bill 330 fn
we've already been before you at least
once that i can recall on issues related
to oplc and
transitioning that into the position and
with appropriate authorities and and
consultancies that are required to make
it function that was intended
uh the oplc has been
um
if you will morphing for about the last
seven or eight years through a number of
different executive directors
relocating which blew their budget out
of the water
and a
number of other challenges we have a
very competent executive director now in
lindsay courtney
it was at her request and with my
suggestion as well that we put 3 30
together here
uh it does a number of things first
establishes a study committee to make
recommendations
about how the board the oplc should
interact with the variances in licensor
boards
and commissions over which it has
authority
as you might
suspect when a change in hierarchy or a
change in structure takes place
sometimes there are difficulties in
establishing lines of communication
lines of authority
and so forth and so for that reason the
study committee is i'm quite sure very
necessary
this bill grew out of a
omnibus bill pardon my using foul
language
and um
uh that was i think the longest i've it
was 73 pages long and that was probably
a little bit too long and of course with
covid that was the end of that but this
is a necessary study committee and i'd
ask the committee to
to move forward with it
two other things that it does it deals
with bringing the
boxing and wrestling commission over
onto oplc currently attached to
secretary of state and the revenues for
which currently all accrue to the
general fund
uh that according to lba that i just did
research with
uh and the third thing of course it does
is it deals with the
uh board of forestry or a foreign of
foresters pardon me
it does a little bit to adjust the terms
to make it more rational and how people
get replaced on those boards
and that is pretty much the summation of
what senate bill 330 fn accomplishes i
would certainly welcome any questions
thank you senator are there questions
representative blackis thank you you may
have just answered my question but i
want to make sure
and that is after the transition from
the wrestling board to oplc
i couldn't see anything that said where
you know they have this taxing and fees
and everything so above cost is that
still going to go to the general fund
does it not need to be explicitly stated
according to lba everything they raise
goes into the general fund okay fees and
of course
whatever inspections they have to
perform and so forth right thanks
represent goalie
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking my question
um
not very familiar with the boxing
wrestling commission
but
do they license anyone or regulate
anyone or i mean why would we put them
in oplc
unless they are actually handing out
licenses so what they do amongst other
things they
they license any event like an mma event
or stuff like that and the licensure is
is required to make sure that the proper
medical personnel are there
uh that the proper protocols for
um
you know any of the events that they do
is there that's an oversight board
basically that that makes sure that
everything's kosher and being
safe as possible
follow-up
i i understand the licensing events but
oplc licenses individuals and that's why
i'm questioning why they're there
because
they are not overseeing individuals and
prerequisites for actual individuals and
licensing for you know where i'm going
with this i do i'm not sure whether they
license whether boxers and professional
wrestlers have to be licensed i don't
know the answer to that
my suggestion would be that may be that
the reason that they do this but again i
i don't have an answer for that
thank you madam chair is it not the case
as i understand it senator that
that both managers and boxers wrestlers
and so forth i don't really know about
wrestling uh professional wrestling is a
kind of special breed of cat but i
believe boxers also have licenses i mean
when muhammad ali was a heavyweight
champion when he was uh he was uh
had his what
yeah i'm saying is it is it not the case
that his boxing license was revoked uh
would it not be the case that uh that
are licensed uh that our boxers and
wrestlers also potentially have to be
licensed as well as their managers i
would surmise that but i cannot state
with authority that that's the case
i agree i don't know it for a fact it
wouldn't be hard to find out though yes
thank you representative pearson and
then lucas
senator am i having a keisha vuja day
here with the sense that i've i swear
i've seen
this is this part of another senate bill
i've seen this language in the last
month
in reference to the moving of the boxing
and wrestling commission what
yes we had a bill to
take them out all from under the
secretary of state secretary of state's
office
how is this different than that bill
well i don't know i didn't sponsor that
bill
because this i mean this
okay thank you representative pearson
we'll have to get somebody to look at
that difference
representative blackis
uh thank you yeah i can answer the
question licensing um 285.11
which is under the uh the boxing
commission
license is required no person should
participate in a professional fighting
sports competition is a contestant
manager referee judge
second or time keeper without a license
from the commission
uh the fee for a license issued will be
uh 20 and then there's some other things
so
if this is moving to oplc we might want
to go with the general oplc of them
setting the fees but otherwise yeah
there's various people that are licensed
what's that rsa 310
mm-hmm okay
yes
i will mention that i intend to amend
the study committee to also include the
funding study that we had in
that was in senate bill 313 yes ma'am
yeah so i think
those of us who would be called upon to
serve on both those study committees
would rather do it
once any other questions for the senator
okay thank you
uh
and laura cooley thank you madam chair
members of the committee
and thank you to senator gaida he is my
senator
and he helped me get my license renewed
when the licensing board
told me they had no paperwork for me
that i'd lapsed and i needed to fill out
the original paperwork again which is
stack about this high for me
i support this study commission on
reciprocity
our board is not the only one i train
all kinds of mental health professionals
and healthcare professionals
seems like all of these
these licenses have a real trouble
getting reciprocity i read of a drug
counselor in vermont that had been
practicing in vermont for two years and
still didn't have their license in new
hampshire so it's obviously a problem in
new hampshire i know our motto is live
free or die but when it comes to our
licensing boards
it's a misnomer thank you very much okay
thank you
questions
yes none
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 330.
seeing none
i will close the public hearing
i have a question in the chair yes we've
been using
reciprocity seems to be a term that's
fading away
and being replaced with recognition are
we do we really mean to say reciprocity
or are we headed toward recognition
are we going to maintain a distinction
between the two
i don't know
well okay i thought i'd ask it's a good
question it's a good question but i
don't have an answer right now
all right
okay
well if i might i would just say in
response to represent representative
siddiq's question that i certainly do
not think we want to drift into a
circumstance in which we equate
recognition and reciprocity since they
are
related only by the fact that they get
both began with re
uh you know
the thing of it is that reciprocity well
i'm closing the public hearing on senate
bill 330 and we are
the reciprocity
frequently requires a formal agreement
between states
what we want to do is find a way to
acknowledge the the licenses
some people get from other states i've
heard the same thing for mental health
professionals having a great deal of
trouble getting licenses in this state
and we ought to be looking at why is
that the case when they're
qualified enough to help it to work in
vermont or massachusetts
you know it's it's not like that those
states have
extremely different qualifications than
we do
oh i i'd very much support the effort to
try to get a handle on this that this
committee has the competency to do
okay thank you
all right um
i was hoping that some of these bills
might be easy
i agree with you i i think there are two
that we might look at okay
which ones are those
i'm thinking house bill 228 on the
physician's assistants and
house sorry sorry sorry senate bill
228 and senate bill 284 on glaucoma
okay do you wish to make a motion on
either of them
i would love to okay
um i would move on to pass on senate
bill 284.
i'll second that
okay so that's by grota and seconded by
marsh do you wish to speak to your
motion
excuse me i think the testimony that we
heard on the senate bill confirmed that
it is a sensible
and practical thing to do for the
residents of new
hampshire thank you
the only thing i would add to that is
that uh
the current statute uh creates a
situation where there's an incentive
both to take care of the patients and on
the part of the doctors to actually
misdiagnose certain kinds of glaucoma
such as pseudo exfoliative glaucoma
which is very uncommon just so they can
actually take care of the patients so to
align our statutes with current practice
makes good sense to me
okay
thank you does anyone else represent
goalie and then fellows
thank you madam chair very briefly i'm
just amazed that it took 20 years to get
this forward to change into statute what
should have been changed a long time ago
thank you for that representative
fellows
so this is just a technical issue but on
page 2
line 21
i'm i'm wondering if um so that starts
with roman numeral four
which says upon certification to
treat glaucoma patients i'm wondering if
that title is not applicable anymore
it's really more something like when
consultation
is required
it's you know just it's like the title
is not but i'm not sure because i don't
know
the there's a and
b
right what they're really doing under
that that what they're really doing is
deleting 4a which is the for 24 months
you shall consult
and simply saying that
an optometrist shall consult with an
ophthalmologist when either of these two
things occur which look to me as though
they're
complications that you want to you want
definitely a second opinion right and if
that's the whole
part if that's the whole of roman
numeral four
then i don't think the title of a pawn
certification to treat glaucoma patients
doesn't seem to be it's it is actually
the
um
up
on page one there's a couple of places
they said
they talk about the requirements for
getting certified to treat glaucoma
and
which are is not an automatic part of
optometry
i i thought we're making it kind of like
an
automatic part of that's what the whole
bill does
yes but we didn't we didn't or they
didn't do it thoroughly they kept the
requirement for certification
it's an all of page one is about that
and so this just says once you've passed
those hurdles by graduating
recently or went out whatever well
that's that's what you do if you if you
think that that that that fits it just
it looks like a connection for me
i think it's wrong okay
any any other comments or questions
representative allegro
well i was frantically digging through
my stack of papers did anybody bring up
the subject of removing that date of
whatever it was 2001 to that as an
amendment
i mean everybody seemed everybody seemed
to um
you know
it raised eyebrows so i was wondering if
we're going to do anything about it
if i may care yes i just um
with the gist of what i got from them
was that with the other changes that are
involved it just really doesn't matter
so
if
if we can if we can get send this
through as it sits without without
touching it
and it works then we don't have to deal
with the senate having to concur
and
all of that i mean
because i because i asked that exact
question what what's up with the 2002
date but they did it's not just a date
it's down until on line 24 it has all
that nonsense about how she that she was
describing how difficult it was to find
the 25 patients because everybody kept
moving or retiring or that's also in
there yeah that but the waiver
yes and the striking out on lines 22 and
now make that
24 month period disappear
the thing is that that's if we were to
start changing that we would have to
change a whole lot of their
of their statute and if you wish to take
that on as a project
more power to you but
we'll next year will we then be saying
it's been 21 years then
yeah like we're now saying it's been 20
years and why no this eliminates most of
the
the restrictions
for the
they already have waivers
i think i'm with representative pearson
in that you either have to completely
rewrite the spill in the large portion
of their statute or you live with some
bad line some some language you don't
exactly like
representative slakis yeah i'd say i
mean it
it makes sense making that change but
maybe you could take that on as a
project for next year
yes the other thing too that sometimes
we get lost in with this of course is
when you're changing
a portion of a statute what what comes
out in front of us is the applicable
part it's not the holistic part
right so there's unless you look at the
entire section of law not just the part
that's changed to make a change in this
that is referenced in other parts that
isn't in front of us has a potentially
cascading effect and a contradictory
effect
and that's certainly something that we
don't we certainly don't want to do
because it will make things worse
and
where we would have to if
something that seems logical as simple
as removing the 2002 date if that has to
go back downstairs the lawyers have to
go through it they have to look for
conflicts if if the folks that testified
seem happy that it's made that date
irrelevant
i just think that that's a you know
you're opening the can there that
it's going to send us down a road that
isn't necessarily going to help the
folks out that were here today
thank you okay representative like
us yeah i'm on board with that too that
none of the proponents of the bill seem
to be advocating
for that change
um
and plus what you two have pointed out
so that's fine by me okay
i cover everything it's just to say
again that trying to
make those potentially complicated
changes at the last minute is probably
not a good idea okay representative
goldie and then marsh
thank you madam chair and i agree with
all that's been said i spoke to those
individuals out in the hallway and i
spoke with curtis berry out there and
they are comfortable with what's here
because i specifically asked if we
needed to amend anything and with what
they've worked on they are very
comfortable with what we have in front
of us to do what they want
so i'm happy with that and i'm going to
support this as is
thank you representative marsh yes i
would just want to concur that i don't
want to upset the apple cart i also want
to point out that as somebody who has
been a hospital trustee for years we
notice that many people like to move to
the lakes region of new hampshire and
retire including some people who are no
longer considered competent to practice
their profession in the area from which
they come
so there's some advantage to keeping the
date in there even if there's no longer
anybody in new hampshire right now that
that would cover because it might cover
people who might very well move here
interesting concept
representative schmidt
okay representative
i heard an old saying a while back and i
like it it's don't let the perfect be
the enemy of don't let the good no damn
it the perfect be the enemy of the god
yes thank you for
keeping us in line
all right anyone else have a comment
suggestion
all right
in that case the motion is ought to pass
made by representative grota seconded by
marsh and the clerk can call the roll
and see if i can get through this
representative rhodes yes
the clerk wrote yes representative
pearson yes representative yakovich yes
representative alekas yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey
yes
representative santo nestaso
representative goalie
yes representative
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative schmidt
yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes
represent representative
grota
yes
representative o'brien yes
the chair
yes
at uh 17 to zero
okay i think so
all right is there the motion passes 17
to zero is there any objection to
consent
seeing none will put it on consent
all right
madam chair i make a motion ought to
pass on senate bill 228.
okay
is there a second second
thank you um i think the the the bill
i'm so sorry um
is one that was put together with
consensus from
all the all the interested parties
um
it currently reflects how physician
assistants work
and puts into puts their rule making
into statute
so i think that this is a bill that we
can certainly pass through this
committee to the house
thank you representative marsh yes i
think this is true it's also important
that we do our best to
support the primary care
practitioners in the state of new
hampshire we know that a great many
primary care practitioners have now
announced they intend to retire after
covet and we could easily be facing a
shortage so making it easier for
physicians assistants to take on that
role is a very good thing
okay
does anyone else have a comment
questions representative
goalie and then uh judy
thank you madam chair and i too will
support this um
and
i think it was a good idea to put in the
uh part that they had the insurance
clause in there because upon you know
reading through the bill on page 3 line
in the event unanticipated availability
of a participating physician practicing
as sole practitioner due to a serious
illness or death if his assistant may
continue to practice for not more than
30-day period without entering into a
new collaborative agreement so that says
they're practicing on their own without
the physician and it is a good thing
that we have them insured during that
time thank you thank you
remember i'm judy yes thank you madam
chair
um
before i support the bill or before
i would like to know
if the physician
make a mistake
what about
the assistant physician
so if the parents sued
the physician
also they're going to sue
the physician assistants
i think that depends on the case
they they'll if they sue the
position physician's assistant
they will probably also sue the
physician unless
unless it's one of these cases where the
doctor was not involved in that
particular case
representative grota
i also would like to remind my colleague
that new hampshire is not a punitive
damage state and therefore
these cases are carefully
reviewed before an attorney takes them
on
thank you
anyone else
or some psychic now that all the
substantive comments have been made i'm
not going to risk an old saying
the reason i've been so dyspeptic about
the
issue of liability is
they can say what they want
but i'm i've never forgotten the case of
a rhoda of a nightclub burning down in
rhode island and the radio station
that's put on the ads was successfully
sued
now maybe they weren't protected by
statute but
i
i'm just disappointed that
people act that way
okay we people do not always act
properly
any other comments on this bill
okay seeing none the motion is ought to
pass on senate bill 228
and the clerk could call the roll
representative rhodes yes the clerk
votes yes representative pearson yes
representative jacobovich yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey
yes representative santo anastasia yes
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
yes representative judy ouimosu
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
and the chair
yes
17 0 also okay the motion passes 17 to 0
any objection to consent
okay well while we're on a roll who was
these
marsh marsh and grota
and
the committee report at your earliest
convenience
and i have a motion on senate bill 313.
and i'm moving amendment number
which i sent to you on friday
second so okay so move by me seconded by
representative rhodes
and i will comment that what this
amendment does is essentially
take out the study committee on the
funding
it's number 1385.
i think it's amendment 1310
amendment senate bill 313
yes
1385 was sent out to the committee on
friday i apologize it could there could
be a different one somewhere
but this one
just
deletes
the um
study committee
and then we will be amending
senate bill 330 which has a
a
broader study committee to also look at
the funding
doesn't it delete
section
um
one
ah sections one and two and the
change to the board of registration of
medical technicians since we deleted
that in a different bill
yes representative like just uh so it
looks like this
replaces the bill so this basically the
original bill with those three pieces
missing and the rest of it's identical
yes
at least that's what i told ols to do
all right thanks
uh representative rhodes do you wish to
speak to your motion there a second
no thank you madam chair you summed it
out
yeah that
all right
any other
comments on the amendment
okay seeing none
the motion is to adopt amendment 1385 h
to senate bill 313
and the clerk can call the role
representative rhodes yes
the clerk wrote cs representative
pearson
yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative santana
yes representative goalie
yes representative shirt
yes representative judy we miss you
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
yes and the chair yes
when the amendment's 17-0 stop right
in that case i move ought to pass with
amendment on senate bill 313
and seconded by
representative rhodes
and
i will just like to say that this bill
continues the process of establishing
that the oplc has the authority of
to set the fees for the licensing boards
it deletes the
contradictory statements in a number of
boards
and some of the boards that disagreed
strongly with the policy were deleted
from the bill in the senate so it's
um there was no opposition to the spill
as amended by the senate
representative rhodes
no thank you
anyone else
representative scitec uh in general i'm
uneasy about the direction of oplc and
when the subcommittee
meets to uh that we've established i i
would like to participate in particular
i think we have a wonderful
uh executive director but this idea of
in collaboration with
i think it should
uh this is more for subcommittee stuff
it should be under das not a direct
report to the governor
uh
things of that nature uh i want
i want a better
law or a better structure
uh i this is not any i'm not at all
unhappy or casting aspersions on the
current executive director i just want
to better
feel more comfortable about the the
whole office and that's that's all i'll
say now well this
the study committee in senate bill 330
looks like they are
addressing that issue among others
any other comments questions
representative schmidt
so i i agree with representative
scitec's concerns uh and i think that we
want to make sure that we're on the
record as we are in our executive
session here stating that we we want to
see the uh
the study committee look at this issue
because the structure i think is is too
loosely goosey and uh and just defective
uh in in several respects so i i hope to
be uh working with the subcommittee on
this
study committee
thank you
yes well it is
i believe several of us will be because
the study committee
has three members of the
house of representatives at least one
from this committee
and we might add more if we
when we add this scope
of looking at the funding
from your lips the gods here madam chair
okay
any other comments on senate bill 313
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
i will add further i think you're
probably all aware that
chair maguire and i have been working on
creating an oversight committee for oplc
somewhat
similar to the oversight for health and
human services to try and
have an ongoing way to alleviate some of
the friction that we've seen between
the administration and the boards so
study committee or no i think an
oversight committee is is a pretty good
indication that
the legislature wants to make this work
anyone else comments
representative seizac i don't want to be
wicked but isn't that oversight
committee the edna committee
it has to encompass the senate edna also
it's it's a mix of
both committees
you don't have to volunteer
thank you
anyone else
okay in that case the motion is ought to
pass with amendment on senate bill 313.
andy clerk can call the role
me too
representative rhodes yes clerk votes
yes representative pearson
yes representative jacobovich yes
representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
santo anastasia
yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative judy lee miss you
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows
yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes
and the chair
yes
17-0 and about to pass the amendment
passes and the objections to consent
seeing none we'll put that on consent
and i will write the committee report
all right thank you we are now halfway
through our senate early bills
um
i don't think there's any other bill
that might be ready
for a vote and
unless somebody else has an idea
all right in that case we're done for
today thank you all we will be meeting
tomorrow and we will have to vote on our
final two cent senate early bills
i like epic
you